bonjour je m'appelle warrosane j'ai 25
ans j'habite de tampon titulaire du PMI
B je possède également une voiture je
recherche une entreprise pour effectuer
un contrat d'apprentissage pour obtenir
le titre professionnel des techniciens
services multimédia et je suis
disponible sur toutes les j'ai le bac
STG technologie spécialisé dans la
gestion des Ressources Humaines j'ai
effectué un an au sein du service des
affaires scolaires en tant que agent
d'accueil administratif j'ai travaillé
aussi également dans le service de
l'urbanisme en tant que agent
administratif pour enregistrer les
PMI de construire les déclarations
de l'entreprise je suis attentif
j'essaie de donner les meilleurs de
moi-même je suis musicien je pratique le
piano est ainsi que la guitare et je
suis aussi également passionné par
l'informatique multimédia j'espère que
ma candidature vous a plu je suis prêt à
travailler donner le meilleur de
moi-même et répondre ainsi à vos besoins
snows